Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to The Plight.
Now I didn't get a lot of backstory on this game but it's an indie horror game from GameJolt
which means that you, can expect some jumpscares.
I don't know when, I don't know how...
Hi.
What happened to my-
Ah.
I didn't know how right I would be.
Hello?
Why is that child murdering his family?
Why is grandma so scary?
Grandma, what have you done?
Oh no-oh...
Uh oh.
Hello?
Hi?
Oh, hey, how's it goin'
I had a feeling! I had a feeling.
I had a funny feeling. Oh, hello.
Why am I home now?
Okay!
Ah, what a lovely house I have.
What a lovely place I live in.
Oh joyous day.
Oh frabgeous day, calloh callay.
Hello?
Who else is in here?
Oh, inventory? Okay, well that's easy enough.
Got a little shrine here.
A little newspaper clipping.
Oh boy! Three local missing children found dead over three years.
Great! This is wonderful.
So happy about this. What's this?
Ah, okay.
I'm sure this is going to come in handy for seeing the jumpscares popping out in front of me!
Of which there's probably going to be many.
Okay, hello!
Hi, oh what a dirty bathroom. Euh.
Does this have something to do with The Grudge?
Cause that- the child was all cast in grey
Which usually means something 'Grudge-like' is going to happen. Nope!
I've, fortunately locked every door in my house
In the aim of preventing...
Wa, this is sparse. This seems like a dorm room
more than a bedroom.
Hello
Drawing block?
Oh, we're going to have story time!
Well, Mommy and Daddy had a child that they loved very, very much,
But one day, everyone died
The end.
Oh God. Oh, hi Grandma!
Whoa, Grandma don't look so good
Maybe you should get some lights in the house, Grandma.
Oh boy
And then you got a new family! A slightly less colorful family.
And then Grandma killed everybody oh my God.
Oh geeze. Well, that page is torn out.
Uhm. Okay!
Oh, I thought there was going to be something behind me.
I'm going to let my guard down for one second.
What is that?
Okay?
Hello?
Alright.
Oh. hey!
Oh! kay?
I did- Oh I'm bowing! Oh, okay!
Ah
And orange
Okay!
What was that?
What happened?
Who did that?
*clap of thunder*
Oh, that's not good
This flashlight does dick.
*rolling thunder*
Oh this flashlight does dick.
Oh geeze, what was that?
Hi, okay.
I probably should go take care of that.
*background boom and Mark's scared noise* Euh
*more scared noises* Euh Euh Euh
This flashlight does NOTHING!
It's a piece of shit!
Oh boy, hello.
*sounds of electricity, thumps, and Mark being scared*
*sound like a heartbeat*
HI!
Who's over there? I don't know who's over there.
Hi? Hello?
*wiggling door*
Hello?
Somebody home?
Hhm.....?
I don't know what to do.
What is that?  Oh okay, is this a clue?
Oh *shaking door in background* sorry
Okay.
Ah, yea, Grandma!
Oh boy! Is there something on the behind? No?
Okay. Now what?
*opening of cupboard and drawer*
Oh, yay!
Oh boy, Grandma!
Grandma... euh..
Poisoned someone?
Okay..
Now what?
Now what do I do?
Guide me.
Oh!
Hi!
What- How long were you there?!
Hello! What are you- Are you okay?
Oh, you don't look okay.
Whoa!
How long were you there for?
And why?
Oh, oh! I got to click and hold!
Oh he's gone.
Oh I'm gone- HEY!
HI GRANDMA!
How you doin' Grammie?
Eugh.
Eat your porridge, I'm guessing; or rice, probably
Hello Grandma.
Ooh.
That didn't do anything.
What did you do, I didn't do anything. Oh!
hi grandma.
What are you doing. Why are we going
through memory lane?
Oh boy. Hello! Aw good.
Hi!
Hi?
What is happening?!
Okay!
That's weird.
That's weird...
Oh, here we go.
Ah good! everyone's being happy!
Grandma's playing with the girl from The Ring.
Inig- Lovely game of volleyball.
that I should know about
oh jeez jeez
well the music started to pick up which
is either good or bad but I'm gonna go
with bad oh hello
ah poison plush oh my favorite plushie
toy
I'm gonna keep it by my bed every night
now I'm going to worry about my own
death
mhm mhm
oh yeah here we go okay hello oh ho all
the game of volleyball didn't go so well
grandma was mad about a cheater ok
everything's fine so far
F*** off with you
catching me on my intake breath
it hurts ok I think it's fine ah damn it
it's not fine was it something new in
here Oh too late too late for what
T ugh too late too late too late too late
- who's that can let me get a good whoa
okay okay
Oh! Okay
Uh uh
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no
ok oh hai woh oh man oh man oh good
oh no oh no ohh nama oh god oh
ok let me get a good look at that oh's
there a plush i can have a hanging plush
oh god oh so horrible
oh there it is ok i got the Hanged plush
great! I'm gonna have the whole
collection got a collect em' all and by
all i mean all of the nightmares got to
collect all of those see this game is
interesting because it's less about like
the straight-up scares and it's more
about building this atmosphere of just
creepiness like the the feeling that
something is going horribly horribly
wrong is something that is is it is
something that I respect and games that
are made because it makes it makes you
think it makes you think that there are
things worse out there than they really
are
and then it meets the expectations
laters is how it should be done but I
can't seem to find the next clue
close myself in the bathroom and forget
about all my troubles
remember the good old days when i was
talking to a blood baby in the bathtub
or the sink
everything was fine then
and oh hello hi
oh I got a key which doors is go to i
found the door
oh don't do that
elderly Chinese woman found mutilated on
home with catatonic child
maybe it wasn't the grandma
maybe it was the kid that possess the
grandma
ok then another key
whoa
no no no no no
no nah no no no ok is it going upstairs
hello oh oh well i thought i was looking
at a pair of legs to a giant creature
who has just rolled up rugs
who oh boy ok so it is it is the child
child is doing all the work that's the
bathtub downstairs
hello hi hello flaming doll
I guess I guess I'll come back for you
in a second
do I need you right now why are there so
many rugs
well it all right oh boy oh boy oh boy
ah that's that's that's drowning that's
drowning right there
well good thing we got such an artiste
I saw something sorry I'm getting
freaked out boy oh boy
just nothing in here
oh I gotta fill up the tub
that's delightful boy
oh don't stick your face in the water
hello Oh God
hello oh no no Graham
whoa oh yeah full house flooded can't
see damn thing
Woah-woah am I supposed to go around and
explore
well I know I can't leave this area hi
ho ho
yeah don't go dunk in your head and
death water
it's no good got the Drowned plush
though this next up is the elderly woman
who was found dismembered in her bed
so what about what about this guy
whoa okay okay okay
oh oh ok
Oh god no!
to be continued what my  murder
the sequel is just going to be me being
brutally murdered in a bathtub and then
being hanged and then being killed a
million times over but that was good
that was well done
I mean the animations were a bit janky
prefer small team and an indie horror
game that was well done they did the
atmosphere and that's what I appreciate
more than a lot of jump scares in a game
they got the atmosphere
I was feeling it like I was literally
feeling it that was good
I enjoyed that and I'm like
that's why I like these indie horror
games because they're small bite-sized
pieces of what's good about horror and
you know you'll come across like the
cliché jump-scare that will be fun
and then you'll come across the game
like this this is just kind of horribly
terrifying you don't want to take two
steps because it's so freaking dark and
I know why they made the flashlight so
dark because it would have been brighter
I would have been able to see more but
the sense of like not having knowledge
of what's in front of my face kind of
led me to believe that there was gonna
be like monsters constantly popping out
from the darkness but that was good my
hair is weird today and ives I apologize
for my weird hair but I just popped out
the shower but thank you everybody so
much for watching, you can play this game
and support the developers down to the
link in the description below
and thanks again everybody for watching!
and as always, I will see YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!